[Musik]
mal ehrlich wir sind von hier aus gekommen
Ukrainer informieren, dass ein Streik vorbereitet wird
auf belarussischem Territorium Vielen Dank dafür
Sie haben uns Jungs gewarnt und buchstäblich
in sechs Stunden
vor dem Raketenstart
haben wir es entdeckt oder mit uns geglänzt
Bösartig ging hier Positionen Ja
im Bereich des Gehirns
[Musik]
auf diesen Positionen und nachdem wir bereits haben
nicht mehr gesehen
während der russischen Offensive
wir haben die Ausstellung in der Ukraine nicht gesehen
[Musik]
Russland blockierte die Websites mehrerer
Medien nach Roskomnadzor
Ekho Moskvy Radiosender und Fernsehsender
Regen verbreitet falsche Informationen über
Aktionen des russischen Militärs im Rahmen von
spezielles Betriebsschutzangebot
DPR und LPR A auf den Webseiten dieser Medien
enthält Aufrufe zu gewaltbereitem Extremismus
gegen Russen und Verletzung
öffentliche Ordnung vormals Roskomnadzor
fing an, Twitter zu verlangsamen und
Facebook im Land
[Musik]